the marvel movies
pay better than the ufc
no no that's not true um i made a lot
more money
in in ufc i i i i made a lot
a lot more money in ufc uh but however
there's guys
that we only hear about the people
who who makes it you know what i mean
like you hear about mcgregor you hear
about jones you hear about
like like i made it to i made a great
great money i have enough money now to
live for the rest of my life and even
not even i don't need money anymore yeah
no seriously
unless i do crazy stupid stuff yeah yeah
you know like
there's always always ways to do crazy
stuff and lose everything
but i have more than enough to live
two three life again you know i'm
very good i'm very good and and then to
take care of my family as well
but the the the sad
the sad thing about it is most of the
fighters
they're not like that most of the
fighters they will finish broken
and beaten and and very bad
it's it's a very bad movie ending you
know for most of them
that's why when a parent come with his
kids to me and say and introduce me
is kids as hey george there's the new
the future world champion do you have
some advice for him i always tell the
kid
i say you go to school you say yes i say
make sure you be good at school because
this is the number one priority for you
yeah
go train if you want do boxing mma
basketball
but always be good at school because
it's your it's your insurance
if in case something doesn't work at
least you have a nation an assurance
you can you can have a real job because
if you put all your eggs in the same
basket
and you only want to become a
professional athlete
and if you reach the age of for example
late
20s or 30s and you realize that you
cannot make it
then it's too late that you have nothing
that you can fall into
to catch up and make your make yourself
for the money that you have lost
so i tell the kids yes try it try to
make
it big try for a career but stay at
school and it's same thing not only in
fighting
there's one on uh a hundred hundred
thousand
same thing in baseball basketball hockey
uh
everything yeah so the the the odds are
very very
very low for you to succeed and it's not
because i made it then i'm gonna tell
you a kid to make it right as well
i i think that's fantastic advice mm-hmm
i yeah what what uh how much does a a
good manager play a part of all that
i mean you're with a aaliyah dolo aziz
right like um
at a certain point are they just sending
over the same contracts or is he just
kind of like helping you negotiate
for more and more and more and more
every time
no i'm with a ca uh and
i was lucky before i got with ca
i was i had advice from
friends that were my friend before i was
popular
so i always had great guidance because a
career of an athlete especially in
combat sport
it's not a straight line and sometimes
it's like when you play poker you have
to bluff
and i remember times that man i'm gonna
tell you the truth my first fight in ufc
i made three thousand dollars plus three
thousand dollars to win
my first ufc title fight against matt
news that i've lost
i was i was i signed for nine thousand
dollar plus nine thousand dollars and i
lost that fight
so i made only nine thousand dollars my
first ufc fight
i made my first million dollars i
remember around my fight
with against john fitch and the reason
why i made my first million
i would not have made it if i would have
not not have played my card well
and my advisors would not have advised
me well so what i did is
the way it works in ufc and if there's
young fighters that listen to me
take some note because it's very
important what i'm talking about if you
want to
retire money to make enough money for
the rest of your life
and not be broke broke when you finish
pay attention to this
so ufc they're not my friends they're my
employer
and they're there to make business they
run a business and it's okay for me so i
have to look for the best of my
interests
so the way it works in ufc is when you
you sign a contract normally they try to
make you sign
a contract for multiple multiple fights
so you know how much you will make for
your next fight your
next one if you win and next one if you
win your next one if you win and let's
say you you sign for us
five fight contract you know how much
those fight fight will
will give you if you win and normally
when as you go in your career that if
you're successful of course
that's mean your stock goes i so when
you're at
your fourth fight and you have one more
left
because you're stuck is high they don't
want to lose you they don't want you to
go to fight for other organization
so they want to keep you so they don't
want you to finish their contract so
before your last fight they're gonna try
to renegotiate
with you and they're gonna offer you
some things
however it's up to you to make the right
decision
and i remember i was in that situation
at one point before my
fight with uh john fitch
and i was fighting for peanuts you know
and
when i say peanuts i was making money
but not money as i as i was deserving
and i wasn't a dilemma because i had one
more fight on my contract and my stock
was high i was the new
rising star i was that was the new
champion beating up everybody
and the the money that they were
offering me
was not good so i had for
for the what i've done you know for for
my
for my level so i had one more fight
left and i said
in their face i had the courage to say
no i'm gonna end my contract after this
one and
stay uh try my chance to see on
to be a free agent because i believe
i worth more money to see who can give
me more
so what happened is one day before my uh
my con my i was i was going to fight the
day after the win
the ufc owner came and
did another another contract for me so
he gave me a contract and the money that
i won and that's when i made my first
millions
of dollars but if i would not have had
the balls
to to do that and hold on to this
i would have be paid peanuts for the
rest of my life
but because it's a business that's how
it goes you need to have the right
advisors
that that because fighting is not a
straight line sometimes you need to put
a poker face and say no i'm
ready to to to take the fight and be a
free agent after
to see who can give me more but if you
do that and you're stuck as i
it's always that chance because you
might lose your fight and your stuff
will be low but if you do that and
you're successful
and the ufc let you go and you when
you're a free agent they're gonna
now it's gonna be like an auction who
will give you more money
so the ufc don't want that because
they're the most prestigious
organization so they have they want to
have the most precision
the best fighters and if if it gonna
make them look bad
if they if they lose you to another
organization so you need to be aware of
that
you know but of course you need to win
to win your fight you need to be
successful of course
man i wonder if uh chandler losing
if that's like such great news for the
ufc because it shows that
the ufc is the more prestigious for the
best in the world
it's very but it's it's always a gamble
in a way that
let's say you're in you're in a contract
that you're you have
you have signed a three fight contract
and you have won
your first to fight and now you're about
to fight your your third fight
if the ufc think that you will probably
lose your
your third fight against the guy that
they're gonna give you
they're perhaps not gonna try to renew
your contract before they're not they're
perhaps not gonna give you a good
uh a good good contract
uh for for to renew it so
and it's up to you to know hey is it
worth it that i
that i think that i i take a chance and
i become a free agent or or
i want you know what i mean it's right
you have to think about it it depends in
every situation but you need to have
good advisors and unfortunately in mma a
lot of guys they have
very poor very bad advisors another
challenge i grew up with guys
that were my real friends so they they
they advised me very well
so when you're coming up on that last
fight in the contract do you think the
ufc
makes that a very hard fight for you so
that you
you not you don't have that negotiating
power do they do they play it like that
well for me i was the world champion so
they always brought me the best guy
i was like i was ready to take on
anybody anytime
anywhere i didn't care i was very hungry
bring it no problem my friend i'm gonna
i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna take care of it
but but
for young fighters you know like as it
go up and rank
you need to be aware of that you know i
see some young guys sometimes they sign
contract for like eight fight deal i'm
like it's ridiculous
because if you're stuck go up
yeah you have no room no no no power to
negotiate because you already signed for
eight fights so if you win your
your first two fight and you're very
successful your six
other fight that's mean the purse that
you're gonna have is predetermined so
you have no power
and a lot of a lot of guys that get
caught with that sort of thing
you know it's it's foolish to think that
that everybody is well managed because a
problem is in them in
basketball in in hockey baseball
american football they have an union
that took care of the
the kids because there's a there's a
plateau
there's a there's codes you know there
is a rules you know to follow there's a
guideline
we don't have any guideline in mma and
and that's why
that's why a lot of the athletes they
they they're broke they have no money
and it's very unfortunate
for that yeah wow [ __ ] so you went from
making nine
thousand two million that john that kind
of yeah yeah
two i i i i made way past that my last
fight
way faster good for you that's because
we got ten fingers holding up here about
about that and with sponsorship and all
that all the deals i have like about
that you know
so just to show you that everything is
possible
and and you you
you know what i mean but you need you
need to perform to be a good
fighter first of course otherwise you're
not going to go to work but you need to
be managed well
and then i'm managed by ca you know in
l.a and
i had a lot of issues when i was young
you know but like everybody else i had
to go in court and i
and i i was badly advised at first
certain
as in certain times but i always had two
or two of my
close friends that i have for a very
long time they
one was a stock broker and then and
another
one was a real estate uh not not
received a stock stock uh broker guy
and the other one was a fiscalist and a
lawyer so they they had
other jobs in the past they they were
not working for me but they were always
giving me good advice and
as time goes on i would add i had enough
money
then i that i hired them to be in my
team and took care of me and then we
went with caa
all together and that's how everything
happened you know but i was very lucky
so because when you when you start to
make a lot of money
a lot of people gonna come to you and
there's a lot of sharks and fighting
it's a world's
world of shark my friends i'm telling
you it's very bad
you cannot trust nobody do you still
have a relationship with ali
oh yeah ali ali is a friend of mine ali
i know him when i when i i was poor i
didn't have money i stayed in his house
uh in new york ali is a good friend of
mine with texas shuttler sometime yeah
ali is a manager he managed he does not
manage me but he managed other fighters
uh he managed um
man i'd like to to link up with him
yeah i think i think i've got some funny
ideas
when when the ufc gives you a 10 million
dollar paycheck i mean
maybe it wasn't all at once but like
when they give do they give you a
breakdown of what
what where it's from or is it just a
check well they're just
like pay-per-views or the the way the
way it happened the way it happened is
they don't give you one check the way it
happened
in mma like the way it happened for me
you can negotiate depend
your pa your power your level of power
of course if you're
you know it's always depend it's
different
it's different from every fighter but
you have enough power that you can
demand
you know a purse to show purse to win
you can demand a percentage of the gate
you can demand
pay-per-views buy because when i used to
fight it was we
made a a lot of money the most of money
i made it was through
pay-per-view buys so i was paid
i was paid to fight as a purse but the
most of money came later
it was during the pay-per-view buys
because i was it was making me a partner
so i was also a partner of the company i
was not only an employee i was
a partner because i i had a good
argument i was telling them that because
of me a lot of people gonna watch the
show
and if you make money it's it's it's
fear that i make money too
because i'm bringing a lot of people to
buy the pay-per-view
so but that's how i used to the system
was
different when i used to fight than it
is now well now
um every world champion if you're the
champion then you get a percentage of
the pay-per-view
for for every champion well not
everybody and now
i believe the structure has changed
because the pay-per-view now is espn i'm
not i don't think that the fighters has
as much power now that they used to be
so like before when i was fighting er
earlier in my career we were allowed to
have a lot of sponsors you know
and we got paid a lot of money now
there's a reebok deal right
and then now it's venom so that's why
yeah when i came back to fight michael
bisping one of an argument
that i was were saying
with my my team and i were like hey yeah
you pay us
a certain amount of money but don't
forget that i lost money because before
i use
to get my sponsor now now i don't get
paid for this so reebok
need to pay me or whatever i'm gonna
wear need to pay me that amount of money
so you need to fight for every inch of
it i don't do that
it's not my job it's not my uh
that's not what i'm good at it's yeah
i'm not you know i'm not qualified to do
that i have
very qualified people that do that for
me and i think a fighter one of
one of his jobs i think it's important
that he
choose carefully his team that he hire
people that he can trust but also people
that
are qualified to do the job to represent
him well
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole yeah
yeah dude